-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about.
I love it.
Well, let's get to some news.
Everybody is talking about this.
The U.S. has examined recovered
pieces of the Chinese
spy balloon, and today they
announced that it had
technology to monitor
our communications.
[ Audience oohs ]
When they heard that,
Siri and Alexa were like,
"Oh, hell no, that's our job.
Come on."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, they were tracking
all of our communications,
including phone calls
and text messages.
The balloon was like,
"Based on what we've gathered,
we should invest in eggplants."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Meanwhile, AT&T told their
customers, "Relax, they can't
spy on you
if you can't get a signal."
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Some more news, President Biden
just said
the classified documents found
at his home and office
were from the 1970s.
Yep, they were mostly about
trying to determine
the exact location of Funkytown.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Some more news on the President.
In a new interview ahead of
his expected re-election
campaign, Biden dismissed
concerns about his age and said,
"Watch me. It's all I can say."
[ Laughter ]
Then someone was like, "Sir,
you're talking to a mannequin."
He's like, "Oh, I'm sorry."
[ Laughter ]
Listen, I'm not saying he's old,
but Biden actually ate the
original Werther's Original.
[ Laughter ]
Does that make sense?
Actually, Vice President Harris
expressed her confidence
in Biden, calling him a very
bold and vibrant president.
Bold and vibrant.
[ Laughter ]
Sounds like something you say
when you're asked to describe
a wine but you don't know what
you're talking about.
You're like, "Bold.
I'm getting a lot of vibrant."
Bold and vibrant.
It's always good when you
describe a president the way
Sephora describes a lipstick.
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this?
Today, a top Southwest Airlines
executive testified before
Congress
over the holiday travel
meltdown.
And just to mess with him,
right when he showed up
for his hearing,
Congress canceled it.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, he said the problem is
solved,
but I'm not sure I believe him.
He flew to D.C. on JetBlue.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, the Super Bowl is
just a few days away.
Are you guys excited about it?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm excited.
I'm looking forward to it.
As you've probably heard by now,
two brothers, Travis and Jason
Kelce, are playing against
each other in this Sunday's
Super Bowl.
So their mom, Donna Kelce,
has been in the news
a lot this week.
And here she is right here.
I saw that -- I know. How cute.
It's like a mixed jersey.
I love it.
So, I saw that Donna packed her
homemade chocolate chip cookies
for her boys in Arizona
and sent it to them.
Check this out.
This is a photo of them.
Isn't that cute?
[ Audience aws ]
She wrote their names and "love,
Mom" on the Tupperware.
Yeah, classic mom move.
I love that.
Well, she also sent cookies
to other people as well.
-Did she really?
-Yeah, first Donna sent cookies
to Tom Brady and wrote...
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-Nice.
-Sweet, so sweet.
-Then she sent cookies to
Rob Gronkowski and wrote...
[ Laughter ]
Then she sent cookies
to Olivia Manning,
the mother of Peyton and Eli,
and wrote...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then she sent cookies to Rihanna
and wrote...
[ Laughter ]
You can't. She's taken. Yeah.
And finally, she sent cookies
to Patrick Mahomes and wrote...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Nice lady.
-Spicy cookies.
-Well, listen to this.
King Charles just became the
first monarch in British history
to be featured on postal stamps
without a crown.
-Ohh!
-Can we see the photo?
Yeah. There you go.
It looks like a sad dime.
[ Laughter ]
People complained he should be
wearing a crown.
Charles was like, "Oh, lick me."
[ Laughter ]
"I'm a stamp.
I'm a postage stamp."
Some big movie news, Disney just
announced that they're working
on sequels to "Toy Story"
and "Frozen."
Yeah, Prince Harry heard
the words "frozen" and "woody"
and had a traumatic flashback.
[ Laughter ]
-Put a crown on it.
-Well, get this, in an effort
to fill seats, I heard that
movie theaters are offering more
upscale food and drink options.
It's weird when a waiter comes
to your seat with nacho cheese
and is like, "Say when."
[ Laughter ]
There's even a sommelier
that you can beckon over.
Like, "What wine pairs well with
'Knock at the Cabin'?"
[ Laughter ]
Something bold and vibrant.
People are excited about this.
Chick-fil-A is debuting
a new fried cauliflower
sandwich.
[ Audience cheers ]
People say it really tastes like
chicken if you just add
a little salt, pepper,
and chicken.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, as I mentioned,
the Super Bowl is almost here,
and it seems like everyone is
looking forward to
Rihanna's halftime show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I got to say, people online have
some pretty wild thoughts
about what song she might do.
I'm sure whatever she does is
going to work, work, work, work
because she's just too good
of a performer.
Anyone who says different is
just being rude.
Boy, girl, everyone loves her.
Yeah, I said it.
She's performing live, and she's
under a lot of pressure.
I mean, sure there's a delay of
about four, five seconds,
but still, anyway, make sure you
get a good seat
for the halftime show
where no one will disturb ya.
I'll tell you, if anyone at
my party isn't paying attention,
they can shut up and drive to
their own house
because the monster performance
she's about to give,
she's the only girl in the world
that can do it.
When you think about it, she's
just what the game needed.
Me? I'm just hoping they don't
stop the music.
Can you imagine if there were
sound issues?
I mean, you'd send out an S.O.S.
to fix that problem.
But I'm sure it will be
just fine.
So from me to you, Riri,
whatever you grace us with,
just know that everyone at the
game will be telling each other
how you run this town.
And when you're done,
take a bow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Umbrella.
♪♪
Finally,
I'm very excited about this.
Super Bowl LVII
is happening this Sunday.
You have
the Philadelphia Eagles...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...facing off against
the Kansas City Chiefs.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, as you know,
after the game,
they give out awards
like Most Valuable Player,
but they also give out awards
before the game, too.
Did you know that?
-No, I did not.
-Yeah, they do.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"Tonight Show Superlatives."
Here we go.
-♪ Tonight Show Superlatives ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Our first player
is from the Chiefs.
It's their quarterback,
Patrick Mahomes.
He was voted...
[ Applause ]
Next up, from the Eagles
is quarterback Jalen Hurts.
He was voted...
"What's up, man?
Can I help you?"
"Yeah, I guess
Charlotte lives here."
Next up, from the Chiefs
is Tommy Townsend.
He was voted...
Oh, is that...?
-Hey.
-Yeah, that's him.
Next up, from the Chiefs
is Andrew Wylie.
He was voted...
[ Laughs ]
-Chug Lord.
-Chug Lord. That's a title.
-Next up, from the Chiefs
is Nick Allegretti.
He was voted...
That's very hard to do.
Not easy.
Next up, from the Chiefs
is Creed Humphrey.
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up, from the Eagles
is Jake Elliott.
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Come on over here. He's just
the cutest little thang."
And finally, from the Chiefs
is Noah Gray.
He was voted...
There you have it, everybody.
Those are your Superlatives.